we're at the jane the virgin crustacean
that's so nice because you should have
told me you have two kids and it's so
nice i could have brought them here and
do that like crafty things and arts
that's we're not that kind of crafty oh
[Music]
hey everyone i'm leanna clara and i'm
outside the set of jane the version I'm
about to catch up with the stars of the
show so come on let's get crafty I
[Music]
cannot believe that we're on Jane the
virgin season four I know thank you all
the things all the universe thank you
guys
what has been your favorite part about
playing really over the Vega being
employed that's the number one thing I
love that being in the employ list of
actors of Los Angeles it's a privilege
and then Evo on top of out of you are
working in a show that is successful and
that the defense like it and everything
does just the cherry I mean that's
that's a blessing this is for all the
stanky breaths that's on the set we have
the beautiful doughnuts this is the
drama that I don't I'd think that it
will go directly to your belly or your
butt depending on the case and how your
metabolism works okay the fruits miss of
life cash roots of life and we have the
avocado with the salmon and and and
today we have bagels all of the carp
yeah yeah all the carbs and we have the
microwave and we also posts amazing the
buckets of evil because what I call them
is it didn't you read my contract only
brown ones all the brown ones me and
Mariah Carey only brown ones we also
have a Rolodex of salsas oh let's go to
the rolodex oh you gotta have the spices
yeah yeah and it's a right now ghetto
lazy susan there we go
that's nice I'm into it
I am doing this food service where you
received your breakfast your snag your
lunch your snack and everything because
I am I have a lot of cravings so if I
don't come into that service I would eat
everything they put in on this table is
not being extremely healthy yes what is
your go-to cheat meal absolutely
everything I'm like yeah but I'm like a
garbage can but I outdoor chocolate chip
cookies that's that's I go there it's so
interesting because now that I've
shifted in my mind and I'm starting to
eat clean it doesn't even feel like a
cheat meal feels like a meal that's
hurting myself because I'll feel it
immediately I've got like sodium in my
leg hands and in my feeds and I'm like
oh that's what causes inflammation what
causes all that so I'm not cheating on
anyone but myself if I do that you feel
me yes very close bear claws those ones
yeah but I love me some dark chocolate
and it's good for you it's good of you
and I like I eat yes like I don't eat
food that's good for mean I eat a lot of
it because I like to eat too but I
definitely just eat things that are
gonna not throw down my energy I don't
got time for that you keep your energy
up because you're gonna be directing an
episode what have you already started
prepping what are you doing right now at
this stage I would say at this stage
I've already gone to editing room I've
seen like directors cuts of editing I've
seen editing room of Jenny
I pretty much have shadowed every single
director because I'm here all the time
yeah so I'm constantly like I'm going
that side by the monitor checking what's
there you know besides that they're
setting up or what's the shot and
thinking of like clever ways to have
done it either more efficiently or you
know a way I would want to so the kind
of prep work is also going through all
the episodes of Jane and seem like the
the tone of our show and really like
putting into the fabric of my body what
kind of shots we usually use like what
is our style and that helps me because
now when we're on set all the time and
I'm so used to like seeing our Jane
episodes and being like oh we live in
this closer and you know like what are
they getting that they probably won't
ever use or what Jenny won't ever use
but I can't stop I'm like obsessed and I
really just can't wait to direct more
and more
I haven't even directed yet and I'm
ready to continue well and I love that
because we need more Latinas behind the
camera yes girl and in front of it so
we're gonna make sure that happens to do
with the shows of producing so
[Music]